[Music]
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator tv
and broadcast on thursday may 13th
i'm katie balls the spectator's deputy
political editor and i'll be your host
this week
standing in for andrew neal on this
week's jam packed show
labour have some soul-searching to do
after the local election results
andrew adonis a minister in tony blair's
government and paul embery are columnist
for unheard if we want to debate
labour's future
could a new leader be the answer to
labour's prayers andy burnham the
greater manchester mayor is now the
bookie's favorite to be the party's next
leader
he joins me to discuss what went wrong
well the party needs a new direction
and why he's just started a column in
the london evening standard
then looking north of the border i'll
speak to our home team
fraser and james about this week's cover
story does nicola sturgeon really want a
second referendum now
covert will come next kate andrews will
go through the latest data coming in
and rachel johnson will be on hand to
talk about the new rules of
post-pandemic conversation
we'll finish on the french presidential
elections where i'll speak to spectator
contributor jonathan miller
along with freddie gray about whether
michelle barnier the infamous brexit
negotiation
has any chance of winning all that to
come in the next hour
before we get going if you enjoy what we
do at spectator tv then please subscribe
to our youtube channel
click the button at the bottom of the
video and then tap the bell icon to make
sure you never miss an episode
and if you want to subscribe to the
magazine we have a special offer for you
get 12 issues of the magazine plus a 20
pound amazon voucher for just
12 pounds go to www
spectator uk forward slash tv offer to
take it up
now first the local elections were the
first real test of kirsten's leadership
and it wasn't good the tories took
control of another dozen councils and
got an
extra 200 cancers elected so what's gone
wrong for the party
is this part of a wider political
realignment
or would a new leader do the trick i'm
joined now by andrew adonis
administering tony blair's government
along with paul embery current labour
member
a lifelong labor member and a former
executive at the fiber grades union
also an unheard columnist paul what's
your diagnosis of what went wrong in
hartley pool
um what went wrong is that the labour
party
has increasingly over year over recent
years become
a middle-class pressure group and the
the old coalition
on which the party was based and on
which it enjoyed much of its success
um was was hardly poor in hampstead it
was
yes a layer of middle class white collar
uh people who supported labour's ideas
of a more egalitarian
economy um but also the blue collar
working-class
base and places lighthearted pool in
provincial and post
industrial britain just look at the
labour party nowadays and think actually
you don't look like me you don't
sound like me you don't share my
priorities you try to overturn the
referendum result when we've already
leave
why shouldn't we vote for you so there's
a huge disconnect which has been
entirely self-inflicted by the labour
party
and paul do you think the choice of
candidate played a role in this because
uh much to be made of the fact they were
someone who had supported a second
referendum
i think the the choice of candidate
obviously wasn't ideal
i mean paul williams was a an uber
remainer um
and in a constituency that voted 70
leave
and in many of these places by the way
people are still bringing bringing with
anger at the labour party over the fact
that they
tried to overturn their vote and the
problem is labor
wasn't exactly spot for choice this is
the problem for the labour party that
old working class element which was once
the backbone of the party um you know
people had come up through the trade
union movement
people had worked in manual labor people
who were based in blue collar
constituencies
and were part of the labour movement
they're just not there in any serious
number
anymore so i would imagine if labor did
want to select a leave candidate
for heart deport it would have had a
pretty hard job to to find someone
that's the problem so do you think
andrew that the choice of a
pro-remain candidate in a seat that
voted 70 for brexit
was a big factor in this or or not no i
don't think it was at all indeed i think
it swings in roundabouts the candidate
paul williams
uh is a local gp and he was in many ways
an extremely attractive candidate
the tory candidate came from yorkshire
and anyone who knows hartley poole and
t-side knows that uh the only thing
worse than having somebody from
hampstead is
somebody from yorkshire so the idea that
the uh
the candidates the local candidates
played a role
i don't think is correct i think as i
say the two people on the ballot paper
in hartlepool
were boris johnson and kierstarma and
they went for boris johnson and
the history of elections if you look at
polling all the way back to the
beginning of polling is that almost
without exception the party that wins
elections
is the party that has the more popular
leader and in the head-to-head
on the leadership stakes at the moment
it's boris johnson not kirsten
paul i disagree profoundly with andrew
that this is essentially just really
a question of leadership this is not a
question of leadership changing the
leader in the labour party at the moment
uh would essentially be reshuffling the
debt chairs on the
titanic this is a question about the
labour party's dna this is a question
about the culture about the structure of
the labour party it runs far wider
than questions of leadership and party
management and the idea that all we need
to do is return to you know some sort of
reheated
blarism i i think that you know for for
all that parts of his essay were right
in the new statesman this week tony
blair
showed a bit of humility and i think
andrew needs to show a bit of humility
it was that kind of blare right embrace
of the global market and everything that
went with it you know the loose
immigration policy
it was the the promotion of cosmopolitan
liberalism
um over over everything else which
alienated blue collar
communities in the first place for all
the good that new labor did it
completely
fail to understand the communitarian
impulse in many
of those communities people's desire for
social solidarity their desire for
stability a sense of belonging the acute
effects that globalization
had in the first uh in the first decade
of this century cannot be
overestimated and what blairism did
effectively
is it laid in train what we're seeing
now in terms of the
the work agenda where the liberal left
effectively just demonized millions of
working-class people as racist
and nativist we saw it in brexit we saw
it well before brexit
and that was that anger was storing up
for years in these communities and i
know it because i lived in one
andrew do you think it's time that you
should show some humility
uh paul mentions that tony blair article
in the new statesman this week where
he says the party has gone too far when
it comes to the so-called woke end
but surely that does link back to the
blair area to a degree
well paul sprayed so many different uh
claims and
allegations it's very hard to get a
handle on it in particular it's almost
impossible
to get a sense of where you would go in
future and what he said because he
thinks the corbyn wasn't the answer
he thinks that blair wasn't the answer
he thinks we've both at the one
on the one hand been too woke whereas in
fact actually tony if you read his
article has a critique
of the problem of labor being seen to be
extremist
on some of those issues all i would make
is two two observations
uh labour won three elections when tony
blair was leader
and it swept all of the areas we're
talking about it held all
almost all of the seats in the northeast
when he was leader and that includes
in his third election so to blame him
for what happened
15 years later i think it's just
straightforwardly unhistorical and
though
times change approaches don't change and
the big problem that labour has
is it does not have a leadership that is
capable of appealing to the north and
south now of course it's true that a
leader has to have policies and ideas
this business uh this idea though that
the policies and ideas of blair were
somehow
the destructive of community
and social progress though again is is
completely unhistorical
it was that labor government that
substantially rebuilt the public
services
massive investment in health education
remember tony blair's mantra was
education education education a huge
expansion of opportunity the big problem
in communities like hartley pool which i
know well i i i i come off a council
estate i've got a pretty good idea what
what
working class people think too is that
though labour did a brilliant job of
rebuilding the public services
what was needed and is needed is a
viable economy
jobs businesses industry in these
communities
and that's particularly true in the
northeast which has had
a really terrible uh 40 years now since
the
decline of the mass industries paul
does some of this come back to brexit
some labour campaigns have said it did
not come up on the doorstep um
but clearly it has been perhaps the the
point where
lots of people who felt disillusioned
with labor finally made the jump
the the labour's policy of a second
referendum was electoral suicide
frankly it was only going to end in
electoral oblivion
if you look at these statistics 50 of
the 54 seats that went from labor to the
tories at the last election
voted brexit the idea that labour was
ever going to get away with saying to
millions of working-class people
um actually we think you got it wrong
we're going to make you go through the
vote again
um was frankly insane uh it certainly
isn't the only factor
as to as to why there's been a huge
disconnect between labour and the
working class but but it was a big one
and i would simply say to andrew look
the statistics show that labour has been
losing the working class since around
about the turn of the century
you know the c2 dees have been voting
for labour less and less and labour has
become more of a
middle class party in terms of
attracting the the abc
ones um and you know the as as i said
the acute effects of globalization in
some of these communities in terms of
rapid demographic change in terms of
de-industrialization
in terms of people's sense of place and
belonging being violated
cannot be cannot be overestimated and
and you know the truth is now that
people in those communities
look at the labour party and i'm a
member of the labour party by the way so
so it pains me to say to say this but
they look at a party
now that is a party effectively for the
professional and managerial classes a
party for student radicals
um a party for twitter a party for
social activists a party that's rooted
in the fashionable cities in the
university towns
and i think that this is potentially a
paradigm shift
you know in 1983 even when labour was
crushed
at the general election under michael
foote against margaret thatcher
labour managed to retain much of its
working-class base
that isn't happening now i mean this is
this is a serious and seismic shift for
the labour party
and unless something happens quite
urgently which goes
far beyond the question of leadership
then the party will effectively relegate
itself to a middle-class pressure group
andrew do you think they might just have
to
look at the landscape and think that if
there is a realignment of politics going
on
their future lies in community towns in
the cities
and potentially in tory home counties
there are some encouraging results for
the labour party
uh when it came to the later results in
local elections
well i actually agree with paul that the
moment labour gives up being a national
party it uh is heading for oblivion it's
either a national party or it becomes a
small pressure group
i think its history is is is wrong
labour held its working-class vote
through all of
tony blair's three elections and indeed
our problem in the third election
was we had a loss to the lib dems in the
third election
because of iraq and iraq wasn't an issue
with
with working-class voters at all but on
his point about it not being leadership
the truth is
like many political discussions you
can't be sure because we don't know what
the counterfactual would be
labor has not had an effective and
popular leader
since tony blair every leader we've had
since all four leaders we've had since
have been
as the polls show and as all of the
analysis of election shows they have
all been less popular than their tory
counterpart
gordon brown was less popular than david
cameron uh
ed miliband was less popular than david
cameron theresa may was more popular
amazingly than jeremy corbyn and boris
johnson
ran rings around corbyn in the 2019
election
so my proposition to you which is that
when labour has had
a good effective strong centrist leader
who's able to
mobilize north and south working class
and middle class that that's led to
success
is demonstrated by tony blair paul says
it's not the case now all i can say is
since tony blair went every leader of
the labour party has been
weaker less effective and less
nationally unifying than the
conservative leader
so it may not be a bad place to start to
get a popular leader
um andrew i just wondered when you
mentioned obviously the party losing
working-class voters
do you think the brexit position that
both you and tony blair adopted
has uh helped keep working-class voters
on side
no i don't actually if you look at the
votes indeed if you look at the brexit
vote half of the brexit vote was in the
in the home counties it wasn't in
traditional working-class areas at all
the big problem was
that for the last five years labor has
been lead leaderless on the issue of
europe
we had jeremy corbyn leading during the
2016 referendum
who was sitting on the fence essentially
i think he made one speech
in the entire campaign and then he said
he was moderately in favor of remain but
not strongly
so if and of course he then sat on the
fence for the whole of the next four
years
when you've got one party that has a
clear and emphatic
and well-led campaign and you've got
another party that has
a weak flabby position which is
untenable in its own terms because
because corbin was facing both ways
surprise surprise it's the strong leader
that wins and it's the weak leader that
loses and i'm afraid
are you saying yeah andrew can i just
think i mean are you saying that had
labor
um been been more passionate about the
about the second referendum um unless
you know ambivalent
um actually we wouldn't have lost
millions of those working-class votes
that actually the way to have gone would
have
been to be more stridently pro-eu and
more stridently in favor of blocking
the referendum result and actually the
heart peoples of this world would have
stayed on board with the labour party it
seems to me what you're saying well
again we don't know because there wasn't
a second referendum
i think we can i think we can i think we
can hazard a pretty good guest
at the time show that if there was a
second referendum there would have been
a majority to stay in the eu
so we but because there wasn't the
second referendum we don't know but if
you're asking me do i think we should
have had a second referendum and would
the second referendum have built
a new labor coalition in alliance with
the greens and the lib dems
and indeed the nationalists in favor of
staying in the eu which would have
marginalized the conservatives and the
brexit party
it is my view that that's what would
have happened it would have also it was
it would have also marginalized millions
of working-class voters it would also
marginalize their core vote but we would
we would have won is the point and that
builds a new core vote but unfortunately
we had jeremy corbyn
we didn't have the second referendum
instead we had boris johnson
who got to a second election before a
second referendum and the election was a
choice between
boris johnson and jeremy corbyn as prime
minister and that was
a film that only ever had one ending i'm
afraid it would be
i think it would be an utter betrayal of
the labour party's entire purpose to say
actually what we really need to do is to
build a new coalition
around young people people in the cities
graduates people who are pro-eu
in alliance with the greens and the lib
dems and that's our new base
actually the reason the labour party was
set up in the first place as you know
was to represent the voiceless in
society the people living in the poorer
parts of our
nation the people in industrial
communities like hartlepool
and the idea that because we couldn't
carry them over the idea of a second
referendum well we should just write
them off and concentrate on a new base
um i i think really would be a betrayal
of everything that we're supposed to
stand for in the movement but that but
you might may not be what you said
andrew
that would be that would be the logical
conclusion
it's neither what i said nor is it the
conclusion it's my view that if we'd
been more successfully led we would have
been able to build a coalition that
included
the lib dems the greens and uh
the uh working class in communities like
around the demand for a second
referendum because we were it's because
we were badly led that we were unable to
do that and that's the reason why boris
johnson preposterously
is now the champion of the working class
in hartlepool
andrew do you think with hindsight
perhaps the mistake later made was not
to support theresa may's brexit deal
there has been the point made that had
they done so
the tory party would be uh divided
potentially you know imploding
and she could have kept on to some of
those voters who had voted for brexit
but also backed labour
now the mistake in hindsight was to
elect jeremy corbyn as the labour party
leader in 2015
and then to allow him to fight a second
election in 2019
whenever the the british people were
faced with a choice as who they wanted
as prime minister and jeremy corbyn was
on the ballot paper they were always
going to go for the conservative even a
conservative as weak as theresa may
at the end of the 2017 election was
significantly more popular than jeremy
corbyn
and boris johnson was head and shoulders
above jeremy corbyn
by the end of the 2019 election both as
a leader but also on economic policy
which is the most important
policy that people fight elections on
where labour's trillion pound
nationalization
program which by the way would have
offered working-class voters in the
north
almost nothing in terms of better public
services or better jobs
that was again always going to end in
disaster it's because labour hasn't been
able to find a good leader since tony
blair that we're in this mess until we
put this right i'm afraid we'll continue
in it
well thank you paul and andrew now there
was one standout performance from labour
andy burnham the mayor of greater
manchester he increased his majority by
100 000 votes
so what can stalmer learn from him can
that success be replicated across the
country
andy thank you for joining us on
spectator tv and congratulations on your
election
so talk us through this how have you
expanded your coalition of voters at a
time when the party elsewhere in england
appears to be in decline
there's a simple answer to that question
katie it's
in taking a place based approach
a place first approach to how i go about
my job rather than a politics first
approach
i was very clear when i left westminster
that you know the point scoring was kind
of staying
there and in this role
it is about speaking first to the place
and place is a unifying factor isn't it
for people
of all political persuasions now some
listening to me now will say well hang
on a minute didn't you play politics
uh in the middle of uh last year over
tier three well no because
i said all along that where the
government gets it right
i will say so um but where they get it
wrong
equally i will say so and i'll do it as
forcefully as i can and
you know i think people saw what i was
doing and
and responded to it so i would say it's
about place first
you know and party comes after that and
that i think kind of speaks to people of
all of all
um all political persuasions and i am
you know incredibly humbled by the fact
that in every ward in greater manchester
i
i uh achieved a majority and i think
that says something that
people are buying into that approach
hopefully but also they're buying into
greater manchester devolution you know
they like the idea
of us being able to do more for
ourselves they like the idea
of greater manchester and the north
having a stronger voice
um and i think they they want the
government to
go further uh on devolving more powers
to greater manchester
and you talked about devolution in your
victory speech but i wondered if also i
mean
if we're looking at trends from the
local elections one the thing is
generally speaking perhaps unless
something had gone very wrong
incumbents seemed to do fairly well so
do you think you
benefited from that to a degree and the
fact that you were the incumbent and
restrictions are easing i think so
um obviously it's been a time when
leaders
regionally and nationally have been in
the spotlight and
we've all had tough calls to make
through through the pandemic
um and i think people have kind of tuned
into what we're doing and have obviously
seen us as a voice for their part of the
world
through this difficult time um but i
think more broadly i think these were
devolution elections
i think the public are saying yeah we
like we didn't know whether mares would
be a thing
in 2017 when you were first all elected
but actually now we can really see the
value of you and i think the pandemic
has really brought home the value
to people um and it's not just obviously
english devolution that is becoming
established through these elections
i think you can look at wales where
labour historically i think has had a
more positive approach there with the
you know very much playing to the welsh
identity and i think that
was rewarded and mark drapeford's
approach to the to the pandemic so
i do think that's what's coming through
you know i think there was a
question mark about whether or not
mayors and
uh devolution in england would would
become established and would be
supported by the public but
i would say these elections demonstrate
very very forcibly that that is what
people uh want more of
and in that post-mortem which has been
going on there's lots of
theories going through the rounds as to
why labour struggled
in other parts of england and you know
across the united kingdom more generally
that as you say welsh labor was uh you
know a success really
um i wondered when you're talking about
things like devolution
and also talk about the success of welsh
labor do you think the party in terms of
uh the main message i suppose can often
be too focused on cultural issues rather
than i suppose economic leftism do you
think that that's a potential problem
um are you talking about in some ways
the culture war
war yeah yeah i i
yes i think there is something here that
labour needs to
think about because sometimes i think
when we're um
dealing with issues of of inequality if
we
i i would make the point at the weekend
that actually
to speak passionately about uh the
unfairness of social
care pay is actually to speak up
for fairer pay for women largely because
um
because obviously the the social care
workforce is is largely women but to
speak in that way is more unifying
message for the country
because you know everybody will respond
to that but if you just talk about
women's pay in the abstract um low paid
men will say well who's speaking from
for me
and i think sometimes you know um
approaching things
through that that way often can see it
cut it doesn't feel like a unifying
message sometimes
uh and i do think there's something
there for the party to think about
how does it you know talk to everybody
in a more unifying way
and when it comes to kierstama and
there's lots of people
uh putting their opinions out there on
on his leadership um
jeremy corbyn has suggested there's a
weakness in uh suggesting that some of
these results are you know the legacy of
him
and ed miliband a different labour
leader has said that it's too early to
blow the whistle on kirsten's leadership
i wondered of those two former labour
leaders uh which do you agree with
in terms of their statements well i
would
agree with ed but i'd probably say in a
slightly different way i don't think
the job has started in earnest yet
because
you know kira has come into a very
difficult situation where he couldn't be
a normal leader of the opposition
obviously he's had a challenging time
being pitched into the middle of a
national crisis and
anybody i think would have um you know
found that
a difficult thing to judge in terms of
what level of opposition what level of
what level of support and i think he's
handled it handled it carefully and
and quite well but it has definitely
restricted his ability to project his
own style
uh to the country so i would say in some
ways the job is really really starting
now and kia has an opportunity now
to um to set out his stall
in a much you know more direct way as
leader of the opposition and you know
being able to oppose a bit more
uh than maybe he's felt able to in the
in the
the really tough moments of the of the
crisis uh last year
and has um because kir managed to reach
out to you to congratulate you have you
have you spoke
uh since since your uh result came in
i've certainly had a very
nice message off of kier we haven't
spoken directly but he did come to
um to manchester uh the week before
uh before polling day and i certainly
welcomed
his visit um and i i just say i mean i
think he's in a position now where
the results were mixed um i think they
were kind of
portrayed early on as though they were
bad results and there were certainly bad
results within it no doubt about that
but they were a little more mixed and
there are there are positives for him
uh in these in these results to to pick
up
but for what it's worth my advice would
be
um firstly support english devolution
you know look at what labour in power is
doing and feed off that
uh both in wales and here in greats
manchester steve brotherham in liverpool
and and also you know give full support
to tracy as the country's first
woman metro mayor you know that's a
great a great story
uh for the party and the other thing i
would say is
you know maybe you know paint things
more in primary colors rather than
sometimes the nuance that we you know
that we see
from labor the caution that we see from
from labor opposition i think has to be
done in that way
um you know boulder strokes um in
primary colors and i think
you know that's that's where i think um
things need to go you know a clear
a clear sense of of labor's priorities
going forward define leveling up
there's an opportunity isn't that for
the labour party i mean leveling up
let's be fair to the prime minister he
he has
finally um brought us to a point where
the country is focusing on the right
issue at the top of the political agenda
regional
inequalities have been neglected by
everybody for as long as i can remember
but finally they are at the top
of the political agenda but the problem
is
it hasn't yet been properly defined as
to what the government means by it and
there was this phrase knocking around
last week that there was quote
widespread cluelessness within the
government about it well that creates an
opportunity
for a labor version of levelling up to
be to be set out that is very much
more about about people rather than
infrastructure
and i would certainly uh encourage kiara
into that territory
yeah i suppose there's a risk in a way
that if if you wait for boris johnson to
define levelling up it it leaves labor
behind so
so now it could be the time for kids
dama to really try and get on the front
foot by doing that
yeah yeah yes i think so um i think
the government will increasingly define
it but i'm not sure yet that it will
that it will be a definition that people
will support because there is a feeling
still that it's about favoring some
places rather than others so leveling up
could be quite divisive actually it's
certainly
sort of starting to shape up uh in that
way so just finally
you have a new london-based column for
the evening standard
announced this week um we've we've heard
a lot from you about obviously leaving
at the westminster bubble
and you know not being a metropolitan
elite so i wondered
what did you always want to have a
column in a london free sheet
is this a dream for you no
i couldn't have imagined really the
circumstances in which it would have
happened but they made an approach to me
it was about a couple of months ago
and i kind of was a bit surprised to get
it but i think it reflects a feeling in
london
doesn't it that it needs it it needs to
engage in the leveling up debate you
know london needs to sort of
get involved here and not just feel like
they're being talked about
by everybody else and london is sitting
there alone so i kind of thought well
actually it's a
it's a good move from the standard you
know because and from my point of view i
need to reach out back to
the standard and say well okay let me
explain a bit more
why we feel when you can hear a little
bit of that anger in our voice about
things like the cost of transport
let me just explain why and if i explain
why i think the
vast majority of people in london will
say ah okay now we understand why
they're going on about it uh so much so
i i see this as an opportunity to build
a coalition of support
around leveling up and actually get
london as an ally in
in this whole uh enterprise the problem
is
not the problem because i understand the
way me the media works i hadn't expected
the standard to announce it um
in the aftermath of the election sort of
uh you know
uh inquest and it immediately looked
like this was some sort of leadership
play for
me which i can assure you katy it
absolutely is not it's a
it's an attempt to reach out to london
to explain
how things seem to us uh here and to
tell the
readers of the london evening standard
that actually i quite love london really
because i've spent a lot of my life
there and
my son was born there and he's studying
at university there so
i'm it may be perceived that i i'm
become very anti-london
i can assure i can assure them i'm going
to be assuring the standard readers i'm
not
i just want great manchester to have
what london has got
yeah because as you say some have read
it as are you parking your tanks on
stama's lawn
uh and you're saying that's not the case
but did you give um kierstarm a heads up
before you accepted the
the column job no uh i didn't
and i as i say this i accepted this
quite a while ago
way before the election so that
hopefully that proves uh
that this was uh for the reasons i've
just explained explained to you
but i didn't and i do want to make a
point here about what i'm doing i i
don't run things by
the labor hq or the leader's office
because devolution can't work like that
i think i i got the vote that i got
because i'm
doing things free from all of that stuff
that goes on in westminster and that
gives you the authenticity i think
i keep saying it i'm just so much more
happy in this job than i ever ever was
um when i was in in westminster just
because i feel i can be myself
i'm in the place that i love the people
that i love and we're doing things to
benefit them and it's it's energizing
and it's it's fantastic
devolution actually this is the thing
about it it is actually the route
to getting people back in touch with
politics i think it does allow us to do
politics differently i don't think
doing the same that westminster does and
just waiting for people to buy back into
it i just don't think that's going to
work i think
labor particularly has to come back at
this this reconnection thing from a
completely different direction
and devolution of power in england
offers that different different
direction
so no i i very much don't
uh run uh what i do by uh
by the leader's office in the same way
if you may remember
um the scottish labour party was often
accused of being a branch office and i
think that that
played a part in in really hurting labor
in scotland well
devolution works if it's really truly
bottom up and it's not
no one's giving you orders to do what
you do and i i very much hold true to
that
thank you andy now to scotland in this
week's cover piece
the spectator's editor fraser nelson
wonders whether sturgeon really wants to
have a second referendum now despite
what she might say publicly to discuss
i'm joined now by fraser as well as our
political editor james forsyth
fraser in this week's cover piece you
say that eunice are actually in a pretty
good
position but if we look at that result
the s p are just one
short of a majority so why is that
well the smp is very good at telling
stories and the story of nicholas
sturgeon
has got for the world right now is that
scotland is a kind of country straining
at the leash
of the union all set to have another
referendum and if you hear the language
the snp is using now that
they were complaining that there wasn't
a referendum bill in the queen's speech
for example that would set the
legislation
for the next year but if you actually
then rewind and say on what basis
is nicholas sturgeon making this point
the opinion polls show that
independence while a bit more popular
last autumn has now gone back to the
kind of support that we've seen
in 2014 referendum about 44
of scots would like to leave the uk and
also
sturgeon herself the s p won fewer seats
than it did
10 years ago so we've seen that kind of
decade of stagnation
in snp support now she told us that
brexit
would mean that people would be all set
to to leave the uk
well that hasn't happened the brexit
vote hasn't helped the s p vote at all
boris johnson supposedly hated in
scotland doesn't seem to have had much
of a negative impact the scottish tories
and got the same vote share as they did
last in the last scottish election
so we've seen the snp with a lot of
things that should move it down from
them
simply haven't so nicolas sturgeon is
engaged
in this rather ingenious game of bluff
wanting to tell england and the rest of
the world
that scotland is ready to go in fact the
battle she has got is not with boris
johnson
it's with the half of scots who are by
no means persuaded
that what she says is making much sense
james i think if we look at the s p
result uh nicolas sturgeon has raised
the touch they've been quick to herald
it as a big success for them
even a mandate for indie ref too but is
the party suffering from the fact they
had such high expectations
and made them quite public going into
the fact that to fall short of majority
does look
like a failure yes i think the view
in uh westminster and whitehall is
essentially this which is
the situation in scotland is not great
but it is nowhere near as bad as people
feared it could be last autumn remember
last autumn
independence was regularly ahead in the
polls nicola sturgeon used to tweet out
poll results quite regularly
there was a sense that there was a a
small but definite majority in favor of
independence
and the snp looked almost a lock for a
majority of hollywood which is a
remarkable achievement in a
proportionate system
so the fact that uh the snp fell just
short of an overall majority
and currently more polls show us
so majority support for staying in the
union rather than leaving it
is i think creating a certain amount of
encouragement
i also think the uk government has
positioned itself in a more sensible
place i think if you
if you look at if you talk to people
who've conducted focus groups in
scotland recently
they say that they think there are two
sets of politicians who will get
punished by electors right now in a
constitutional question
one is the politician who wants to have
the referendum almost immediately
and the other is the person who says
kind of glibly well you can't have it
for another 50 years
and i think the danger was at the start
of the year is that danny street were
falling into that trap boris johnson
suggesting that you
shouldn't have another referendum for 40
years i mean now the government is
saying look now is not the time as you
recover from a covert pandemic
nicola sturgeon is having to agree with
that uh
and i think that and you so you are you
are pushing back the date
now i think it is certainly the
government won't grant a section
30 order and i think what you will see
over the next
few uh months is the smp trying to kind
of whip up a sense of grievance
to push the numbers supporting
independents up and i mean the crucial
thing is that the uk government
turns the cheek nicolas sturgeon wants
lots of arguments about you know
she wants uk ministers saying we'll see
you in the supreme court if you
legislate for a referendum
the uk ministers just need to sidestep
those questions
and fraser i wonder you were talking
about the polls and how
actually from the unionist point of view
things are looking better than they did
six months ago is there an argument that
the uk government should just call nick
of the sturgeons bluffs say
you know what have your independence
referendum we think we can win it and
that way
actually finally perhaps put things to
bed
so this is where i think the tories look
and
there will be some people who would
think look let's call her bluff
have that referendum let's make the case
for the union let's move the
conversation on
to questions like what currency would an
independent scotland use nicholas
sturgeon claims
that she'd have a scottish currency in
which case who would pay
people's pensions what currency would
those pensions be
paid in there's so many questions that a
referendum campaign would open
but i think would really underline the
power and the beauty and the point
of the union but then again you could
argue
that um the uk should never shouldn't be
sucked into
this never-ending trap that they should
not be playing the snp's game by having
a referendum whenever the snp
wants one um personally i'm more i'm
more attracted to giving nicholas george
in the referendum if she
passes the votes in parliament asking
her for one and
but i'm aware that you know there's
quite a lot of unionists who think that
would be a disaster
and playing straight into her hands
james are you one such unionist
well i i think what you look at the
election results in scotland
and what you cannot see from them i
don't think
is an overwhelming desire to have a
second independence referendum
that was a big part of the snp platform
and
uh they didn't get over 50 of the vote
if you look at the
constituency vote very marginally more
people voted for unionist parties
than parties that favor independence if
you look at the list vote
by an even thinner margin uh people
voted uh more people voted for
pro-independence parties
than uh unionist parties but given that
the most recent referendum
was in 20 the last referendum was in
2014.
uh i really failed to see that there is
a there is any kind of super
supermajority in favor of independence
among the electorate
that would justify going back on the
once in a generation
sense that that referendum was meant to
be for a generation on the basis that
you
couldn't ask such a divisive and
destabilizing question
you know every other day um so i don't
see
that these elections actually
particularly strengthen the case for
independence they certainly don't
suggest
that there is you know 60 percent of a
scottish public but is desperate for a
referendum
um but james what i'd like to know is
if the snp were to vote in parliament
for a referendum
what would your position be say no or
caller bluff
my my personal view is that if the
scottish parliament was to vote for a
referendum
now based on these election results i i
don't think that
is a sufficient basis for a referendum
so james if you're opting for the say no
approach in those circumstances can you
talk us through
well i mean tactically i wouldn't have
the uk government say no
i would i think it would be much better
to have a private citizen
challenge the uh the law in the court of
session uh the court of session is
uh is a fairly uh conservative with a
small c
court and i think it would be likely to
strike the law down
on the basis of the constitution as a
reserve matter and have you got any
private citizens in mind particularly
i don't but i i fraser says in his piece
and i and this this chimes with what i'm
hearing as well
is that there is already that kind of
funding in place for that private legal
challenge and and if
you buy some quirk of constitutional law
they did manage to hold the referendum i
think a referendum held in these
circumstances should
he simply boycotted by unionists because
the only basis on which you could hold a
referendum would be
uh without the consent of the uk
government would be on the basis that it
had no legal effect and i think unions
should say look we're not part
we're not participating in a referendum
but it's only taking place because it
has no effect
thank you fraser and james so what of
the cover picture
next week marks the latest unlocking so
how do the figures fare
i'm joined by k andrews our economics
editor to give us the lowdown
thanks katie well all of the covert data
continues to look good and it has done
for some time now
as you can see from this first slide
cases are down by nearly 97
below the winter peak hovering around
where they were in early september
now i think what's notable here is if
there had been a spike from reopening in
schools shops or outdoor hospitality you
would certainly expect
to see that evidence by now and
meanwhile hospitalizations are down
nearly 98
below the peak and deaths 99 below the
peak
and while the numbers that we want to
see plummeting are doing so the numbers
that we want to see rising
are also doing so accordingly as you can
see here the antibody data from the ons
which comes out every two weeks and
today the latest set of data has been
published
is looking really positive it's not as
big of a jump this time around
we found this data can stall and then
surge but they're still really exciting
figures
so in england seven out of every ten
adults are estimated to have antibodies
it's six and ten in scotland wales and
northern ireland
and of course that now covers the most
vulnerable and elderly who were
prioritized to get their first vaccine
and you can see the data more clearly
here when it comes to age breakdown
some 85 of the over 50s have antibodies
well the level is closer to 95
for the over 80s that is exactly who we
would want to have
protected first and what you're seeing
here is the vaccine factor in action
with covacases on the ground
it's clear that this immunity isn't
happening through natural infection
but from jabs so what does this mean for
our economic recovery
well the key one figures were out this
week which you can see here
showing the economy contracted 1.5
percent in the first
three months of the of the year now
that's not good news
so to speak but if you consider that we
were in a very strict lockdown for that
entire time
that gdp fell by just 1.5 overall
once again illustrates the extent to
which businesses have developed a
resilience
to lockdowns especially if you can if
you compare this dip
to what happened in the first lockdown
last spring in q2
we saw the economy contracted by a
staggering 19.5
percent the largest fall on record so
clearly businesses are learning to
handle these extremely
difficult restrictions and you have the
furlough scheme which is
helping to support businesses that
simply can't be open legally
right now growth in march which you can
see on the red line was better than
predicted as school reopenings were the
only really big
liberalizing event that month and in
fact recently forecasters have been more
bullish
upgrading their predictions with the
bank of england revising its forecasts
up to seven percent growth this year
ey goldman sachs and others have also
been upping their forecasts over the
past few weeks
so is it all good news well as ever with
this virus any
kind of optimism must be met with
cautiousness as well
so far the prime minister has kept to
his road map those dates seem to be on
track
but there has been talk over just the
past 24 hours
of concerns over the indian variant of
the virus which we simply don't have
much information yet
about how it interacts with vaccines and
if there were to be any delay in
reopenings either next week or on the
21st of june
or if major restrictions were to stay in
place like one meter plus rules around
social distancing
that could have a major impact on the
upside scenarios that i've showed you
today
back to you katie thank you kate
so if the data continues in this
direction socializing appears to be back
on the foreseeable
but are we ready after months locked in
her homes
are we going to run out of topics or
only have to talk about covert
in this week's magazine rachel johnson
sets out her new rules of post-pandemic
interaction she joins me now rachel talk
us through the new rules of engagement
yes i can i'd be delighted to i think we
should all stop
talking about which vaccine we've had
and how many
episodes of it which vaccine we've had
and how we felt afterwards
i think we should all stop talking
speculatively or
not about whether we've had the virus um
although i have to say i i did used to
do that myself
i think we should stop talking also
weirdly about
the variants i think we've got to accept
that
the vaccine was the cavalry it rode to
the rescue
as a country we've been saved like
blocker at waterloo
coming to the rescue of wellington and
we've now got to look forward and we've
got to look outwards away from our sofas
and our
our sourdough and start talking much
more about things we're going to do
to save the creative sector to save the
hospitality the catering and the tourism
sectors i want people to say
i'm going to the royal academy
to look at the hockney or i'm going to
paris to look at the picasso
i'm going to i'm going to go to that new
restaurant that's opened in shepherd's
bush
and just to externalize their lives a
bit more
and not talk about the same old topics
that we have
we have drilled down on deep dives
for over a year and what's the worst
covered conversation you've had over the
over the past year i reserve a special
displeasure for when people ask me about
my children
i don't mind and i actually welcome it
when beloved grandparents
aunts uncles god parents make inquiries
because i know they love
the people in question and they have
known them since birth
but when people who have never met my
children
don't know their names ages or
occupations demand
for me to kind of tweet out their cvs
and go through each one's career path i
don't regard it as polite
conversation i regard it as a total
waste of my time and also of their time
unless of course they're keeping a
private tally of
um what other people's children are
doing for their own
competitive purposes so they can compare
my children to their children and say
you know
you know you're one's working for a nap
in the east end well mine's been running
a charity in paris
you know i just think it's an it's
completely non-productive and
puts me in a terrible temper and what
about the road map should we be talking
about the road map are we allowed to say
june
21st um should we be looking at the
green list and talking about which
countries are up or down or is that also
quite triggering
i think that holidays are so uncertain
that
the only conversation you have circles
back to well if it's on the green list
then i should be all right and i could
do test and release on day five
you can't believe it's a world of
boredom i think was it victor hugo said
you know more
terrible than the hell of suffering is
the hell of boredom and i feel that
we've got to
recognize this and actually sort of you
know stop and check ourselves before we
have these conversations after we've
been waiting to go out for over a year
so it's an unutterable waste when you
find yourself in some pub garden
and have the sort of conversation you
had over zoom during lockdown
you know have you had the virus have you
had the vaccine where are you going can
you go
um what was you know what about a
quarantine hotel it's
it's too boring we've got to stop i mean
no i'm boring my i'm boring myself
having this conversation by the way
it's not as if i'm dorothy parker or
anybody but i think that we just as a
nation got to got to do a bit better i'm
sure they're not talking about this in
paris even though they've got a
recon fina mar and they have to have an
attestation to go about
five yards from their house i'm sure
they're talking about culture and
and sex and um you know fashion and
and food in a way that we're not and on
the subject of sex one of the things you
say in the piece is there's been a surge
in physical activity
uh in this manner perhaps because we are
so bored of
talking to each other for some of the
reasons you've outlined
do you think that could be a right topic
for conversation
yes i think so although i have to add i
was quite surprised when i read that
wreck-it
the manufacturer of condoms had
announced a double digit
no pun intended rise no pun intended
in the sales of durexes because i think
this has been the
least sexy year in human history
the pandemic of 2020 to 2021
but so my only construction i can place
on this is that conversation
is so boring and so limited that
couples uh or strangers far prefer to
exchange
body fluids than trivia
and have you got any big social events
planned uh
where you're going to put these new
rules of engagement to the test in the
coming
weeks or months i did i had a lovely
dinner i hope he doesn't mind me name
dropping
with johnny bowden outside in the ivy
and
um before we started dinner i
i laid out the stall i said these the
banned topics
and so we didn't talk about the virus
the vaccine lockdown
holidays and we had such fun but
unfortunately
as a result we broke all ellen and
roosevelt's rules of conversation which
are all about how
little people talk about people and big
people talk about ideas
of course we had a just a long and very
pleasurable gossip
which would have had eleanor roosevelt
uh turning in her grave
the whole point of going out is the
exchange of gossip i mean
you as a political journalist know that
politics is essentially gossip and many
of the political stories you read in the
newspapers are people exchanging gossip
um and what was saying dispiriting about
lockdown was nobody was going out and
doing anything so
gossip just dried up and so i was like a
plant that withered
and now of course i'm you know we're
watering the plant a little bit more
but we've got to be careful to water it
properly so that it thrives and it's not
just gossip
we've got to talk about politics we've
got about foreign affairs ideas
the wokery of the left all these topic
these are really interesting things so
we've got to stop talking about the
virus and the variants
and finally what's going to happen
rachel if you invite someone around
and they fail your test and they start
going on about face masks
and children yeah well i mean don't get
me started on face masks
i think that they are pretty useless and
they just virtually signal that you are
compliant with um
you know the state interventions into
all our lives and
you know you vote you voted for biden um
i can't wait to get rid of face masks
inside outside and at schools and in
shops
um so i'm quite happy to have that
conversation actually because i find it
quite triggering
but but children katie maybe you can
help me on this one
uh what should i say when people who
don't know them ask me about my children
because i'm
trying to find i'm trying to work out a
non-aggressive way of responding to that
question i think if they don't know your
children you could just say you don't
have children
and see what happens
that's a really good idea i'll try it
thank you rachel now finally let's go
across the channel to france
former brexit negotiator michelle
barnier thinks he's in a shot at the
presidency
but not everyone else is so sure among
his pitch is an idea to stop
immigration from outside the eu for up
to five years
so does he stand a chance jonathan
miller says
not in a piece of the spectator's
website this week he joins me now with
freddie gray the spectator's deputy
editor
jonathan the french presidential
election continues to get underway
but can you talk us through this new
entrant introduce us to the man michelle
barnier
well michelle barney is one of these
guys who doesn't need a lot of
introduction
especially not to the british because he
was
the uh the chief negotiator of the
european union
through the old brexit saga and uh he's
now
apparently decided that he can serve his
country by returning
and possibly making a bid for the
presidency
which uh is a little bit interesting
we're not that interesting because i
think he has absolutely no chance i
think
the only people who are really
interested in michelle barnier these
days
are the brits uh
freddie do you think that's fair are you
interested in michelle barnier
he has received plenty of criticism
particularly from the uk press during
the negotiations but
nigel farage has praised him
i'm not particularly interested in
michelle barney i do think it's
interesting
uh that he felt his way to make a splash
um in the presidential race was to to
declare a a stop on immigration
for the french which is obviously very
rich given uh the brexit negotiations
and all the arguments about free
movement and so on
uh but i think as jonathan says in his
excellent piece for us that um
i can't really see this campaign going
anywhere
well jonathan what's the point of this
campaign then because as as you say in
your piece he's not really registering
in any polls do you think uh thought
he'd do better
or is it something else that he's trying
to achieve here
i think there's a kind of uh you know
[Music]
he's in brussels he was kind of exiled
to brussels
about 10 years ago where he's been a
kind of gray man
a functionaire you know a master of
dossiers
um his work is kind of done in brussels
uh macron doesn't really like him
he's kind of of the right he's 70 he
feels pretty good he thinks he can come
back
and maybe re-establish some kind of
political career in france
i doubt that even in his wildest
fantasies he imagines he's going to be
president
but possibly he can talk himself into a
ministerial
role in some new government and uh
collect another pension on top of the
half dozen i imagine he already has
and jonathan how is the campaign looking
more generally
the broader picture what about macron uh
the incumbent
well see i think you know this is the
campaign that keeps on giving as far as
journalists are concerned because uh
every day there's a new little mini
drama
macron is uh i think he's lost in cloud
cuckoo land he's talking about the
future of the eu
but that's not really what people in
france are talking about they're talking
about security
we've had two more policemen a
policewoman and a policeman assassinated
on the streets of france in the last few
days
[Music]
you know we've had constant videos
night after night from various uh parts
of france where people are throwing
you know uh fireworks at the police and
setting fire to police cars we see
uh videos of women being pushed down
the steps of the paris metro we
uh and people i think is does all the
polls are
pretty well agreed people are interested
in security
and macron has no answers to that
problem
freddie talk us through these letters
from the military on
islam well i think it shows just how bad
things have got in france uh i mean uh
there there are some generals
uh that i mean among military sources
i've spoken to there are some generals
uh who are considered a little bit too
political already but certainly there's
a feeling that the the generals that
spoke out in the first letter warning
that france
could be descending into a state of
civil war there's a lot of public
support for it and there's a lot of
support within the military because
there is a feeling in france that a lot
of the towns in france a lot of the
cities
are out of control there are a lot of
places where law and order does not dare
to tread
and that's quite a dire situation and so
the generals felt compelled to make this
uh statement with macron and it was
interesting actually macron was smart
enough
in his response to the first letter not
to go nuclear he didn't actually go on
the offensive
the signs are his government are going a
little bit more aggressively against
this second letter
from the soldiers but i think that
a sort of potential clash between the
president and the french military
it's not out the question and that's how
dire things are getting in france
well i read the other day in this um
[Music]
that the police are also there's a
there's a police letter as well
to current soldiers and retired soldiers
and one of these letters makes reference
to 600
600 parts of france where the police
don't really want to go
i mean i thought it was 20 or 30 600
neighborhoods they want to stay out of
um
that's that is you know pretty dire uh
well i was very interested i was very
interested jonathan you wrote a
brilliant piece for us
uh recently about eric zemor running for
president
this sort of possible campaign and how
successful he could be if he ran
and just to explain to viewers he's a
sort of intellectual tv intellectual in
france of the right
and uh i i i noticed that the the the
magazine behind these letters
is edited by a young frenchman
who actually wrote a novel in which
zemor is
is cast as as the as the savior for not
the savior of france as someone who's
becomes president of france
do you think that fiction might be
playing out in reality well it's very
hard to know
uh zamor is an interesting guy he's very
very
very brilliant even people who voted for
marine le pen
are kind of fed up with her because
she's putting on such a feeble effort
despite everything
um zamor hasn't announced whether he's
gonna go or not
there's no doubt that zamora has enemies
uh on the left in france who will use
the kind of the mood of me too or
balanced
to attack him for his what appears to
have been a um
a pretty uh a pretty uh active french
life
um in his past um
i don't know whether he'll go or not he
needs money he needs organization
um could he see off marine le pen
it's hard to know the situation is so
confused every
barney who we started out talking
talking about barney
hasn't even the question hasn't even
been asked in the mainstream polls would
you vote for barnier
and on the long long list of the of the
betting odds
which has got about 40 or 50 names on it
his name doesn't even feature i i asked
my normal focus group at the bar rex is
suspended
as a result of the lockdown at the
moment but i've been asking
people that i meet at the market on the
street um
what do you think of barney and there's
like a look of incomprehension
nobody's even even heard of him as for
the rest of the race it's so dynamic and
in such a state of flux that nobody
honestly
can say what's going to happen except
that there seems to be
this kind of growing belief that somehow
despite everything
marine le pen could potentially beat
emmanuel macron in some kind of donald
trump
moment when the french
finally say we've had enough of of you
know
of immobilism of just going nowhere for
40 years
fred you've got a reputation in the
spectator office as a betting man
who's your money on when it comes to
this rather confusing race
i think it has to still be on macro uh i
mean he is the favorite in the betting
markets which i have looked at
i have kept an eye on believe it or not
uh
and i think the reason uh he has to be
the favorite is that he's blessed
like boris johnson he is blessed with
terrible opponents
um le pen obviously isn't a very strong
position but she's not coming across
well
um she's had fallouts with various
people
on the right um the left is in complete
shambles
the republican the center right is sort
of crying out for a
a good leader but they seem to always
murder each other um
but of course unlike boris johnson
macron is is very unpopular and not
loved um in any way
so i think despite uh his his
terribleness as a president in many ways
i mean he's seen as this sort of
posing figure again to go back to the
army thing i mean he did this ridiculous
stunt where he wore a
pilot flight suit like george bush did
um in iraq and it and it was seen as a
sort of
appalling breach of etiquette in france
and yet he did it you know and he's seen
as this ridiculous figure but
nobody it seems capable of mounting a
successful challenge or even a very good
tactical one
well you know i i agree with everything
you're saying i agree that
on the odds that macron would still be a
slight favorite but it's not impossible
uh that he could be uh he could be
deposed by uh
by le pen what is shocking really is it
none of them
none of them i've got any kind of
project
or leadership or you know ideas
for leading uh france uh to a better
place
uh macron was elected having this
project
none of which in fact he's implemented
in his clumsy
um his clumsy maneuvers uh
stimulating the the gelatin and
making promises he's broken to the
environmentalists
now cozying up to the right declaring
this ineffective war on islam
but he he uh he
his project seems to be more europe and
i have to tell you that doesn't
that doesn't cut much uh gray poupon
mustard at the cafe de la pay
here in in the corner of our village um
people are more interested when their
kids who they've sent away to
university call them up at one o'clock
in the morning and say
i was walking home and i just got mugged
uh and my iphone has been stolen
and um and i think that's the cut
through and that is where
macron's very vulnerable having said
that
marine le pen has has no vision really
to offer france
um the socialists you've sort of
led by this kind of melanchol who is
really almost a comic figure um
the republicans are trying to do deals
with lafayette public or march to try to
get some kind of
representation in the forthcoming
departmental regional elections
the country's in a very very uh tender
place at the moment
i don't think it's on the verge of a
coup d'etat but it is on the kind of
is in the middle of something resembling
a nervous breakdown
thank you jonathan and thank you freddie
and that's it for this week
if you enjoyed this episode why not
subscribe to the spectators youtube
channel so you never miss an episode
again just click the subscribe button at
the bottom of this video
and thank you for watching and do join
us again next week
[Music]
you